as far as you know did you pick the
genes that you have and the answer is no
uh if you don't like the character can
you change the genes no
and then we tell you the genes turn on
and off by themselves which then all of
a sudden really makes you a victim of
your heredity oh my god there's cancer
running in my family heart disease or
diabetes and and and then what does a
person take home with that message and
says oh my god i got the gene and then
their visualization process sees them
like i'm gonna have this problem
well
of course that's what i was teaching in
medical school for years and then i i
was um back i hate to say this because
it's dating me in the last century uh
back in you know 1960s late six yes i'm
that old back in the 60s uh i was
growing what are called stem cells in
tissue culture and stem cells are
embryonic cells
and all of us have stem cells if you're
out there listening to this program you
have stem cells for a very important
reason a body is not a single entity
it's made out of 50 trillion cells but
every day we lose hundreds of billions
100 i mean these are numbers that are
it's easy to say 100 billion i say start
to count to 100 billion it'll take you a
year or two to get there uh and i guess
so hundreds of billions of cells die
every day that's natural
the issue is well how long can you live
if hundreds of billions are dying every
day answers well
every day we make new hundreds of
billions of cells and i say from where
and i say stem cells and i say what are
they embryonic cells why don't i call
them embryonic accessible after you were
born you're no longer the embryo we
changed the name same cell though
so i put these i have these
multi-potential cells i put one cell in
a petri dish by itself and it divides
every 10 or 12 hours so first there's 1
and 2 4 8 16 doubling at the end of a
week 30 000 cells in the petri dish most
important point they all came from the
same parent so i have 30 000 genetically
identical cells i split them into three
petri dishes
and so 10 000 in each but all dishes
genetically identical
and i then grow cells in what is called
culture medium this is the secret
i said what does culture mean it's a
laboratory version of blood
cells grow in blood
and i go okay so when i grow human cells
i say what's human blood made out of and
i make culture medium in a lab but since
i make culture medium i can change some
of the composition so i make three
different versions of culture medium but
three plates of identically genetical
genetic cells and
in culture medium a environment a
the cells form muscle
in another dish genetically identical
cells but a different environment b
different culture medium they form bone
and in the third petri dish again
genetically identical cells but
different environment the cells form fat
cells so i say well
what controls the fate of the cells the
answers they were all genetically
identical the only thing that was
different was the chemistry of the
culture medium and all of a sudden this
leads to a whole new science genetics is
a science of genes control a disease or
genes control a character
this new science and this is really
critical it's called
epigenetics i say what does that be well
epi means above
so we call skin
epidermis which means above the dermis
that's where the skin is so i said what
is epigenetic control that means control
above the genes
what do you mean i thought genes turned
on enough by themselves i go no genes
are blueprints they're blueprints to
make the proteins of the body 100 000
different like lego parts a hundred
thousand different pieces you assemble
some it's a muscle cell you take some of
those proteins assemble it as a brain
cell uh so i have a hundred thousand
different proteins okay
and the genes are blueprints and i say
well what's the relevance and simple
point it says to go into an architect's
office and she's working on a blueprint
ask her hey is your blueprint on or off
and she was looking you go
it's a blueprint there's no on and off
it's a blueprint like oh he's precisely
jeans are blueprints they cannot turn on
and off
but an architect can read the blueprints
and adjust the blueprints and i go well
what's the architect that controls my
genes
well here's the story we'll connect it
very quickly and that is this
i said i was putting blood
you know equivalent in the dish called
culture medium and growing the cells and
the culture medium composition changed
the fate of the cells and then i go when
you look in the mirror and see yourself
i go that's an illusion of a single
entity because each of us is made out of
about 50 trillion cells we are by
definition not a single entity we are a
community of 50 trillion cells those are
the living entities and i go so what i
go well inside under your skin you have
the original culture medium blood
and i go wait
the blood chemistry controlled the fate
of the cell cycle yeah it does in a
plastic dish but i say it does the same
thing in the skin comfort dish so all of
a sudden now i say is it your genes that
control your life and i go no it's the
blood composition that controls the
genes
now we take it there's two steps now one
step is well then who or what controls
the chemistry of the blood i go the
brain controls the chemistry of the
blood
and then comes the big one
so what chemistry should the brain be
putting into the blood and the answer is
whatever picture you have in your mind
the brain will translate that into
complementary chemistry and then release
it in the blood and then your cells will
conform to the picture in your mind
picture of health cool
fear disease not so cool but the point
about it was what the genes had no
decision making in this it has to do
with what are you thinking
consciousness is changing the chemistry
and the chemistry complements the
consciousness so
if i have a picture of love in my mind i
release wonderful chemistry into the
blood dopamine pleasure that's why we
always fall in love it feels so good i i
said what else you really oh oxytocin
that bonds you to the loved one and i
said what else vasopressin a chemical
hormone that makes you more attractive
so your partner stays with you longer
and most importantly when you're in love
you release what's called growth hormone
and growth hormone does exactly what it
says so i say so what's the relevance of
the chemical cocktail
derived from love and the answer is
vital very vital life people in love
glow they're healthy they're vital
they're vibrant i go is that what a
coincidence i say no
it's the chemistry
in the blood that is controlling the
genetics and the behavior
you say well wait so if i have a picture
of fear i say do i release love
chemistry no no
fear has its own chemistry stress
hormones and things that regulate the
immune system so i say so what the
picture i'm holding
changes in the chemistry the chemistry
then controls the genetics and the
behavior
fear causes stress chemistry stress
chemistry shuts down growth
uh and there's a reason let me give a
reason why the biggest issue on this
planet everyone says where's all the
illness coming from got healthcare
crisis everywhere i go
not from the genes
less than one percent less than one
percent of diseases even connected to
genes
well then all of a sudden so where the
hell's all the disease coming from i go
the consciousness of the individual
is selecting the genes and as an
architect can alter the readout of the
genes you can come with a normal gene
but with a picture that's skewed
you can alter the readout of the gene
and make cancer 90 of cancer is not even
genetically connected in the family you
know that's a that's a hard thought for
a lot of people because it it but it's
an also extremely
powerful one because it means that
there's you have control but it's also a
really hard one because it means
you are the reason
and so
accountability i think is a is the word
that comes to mind with all of this i
bring this up and then i say well we are
creating this with our consciousness
what's going on and then people go back
over their life and they go
i created the cancer i created the
problem and of course the first thing in
the mind is going to go no i don't want
to take credit for that
i'm a victim
and now i need to and this is so
critical i'm glad you brought it up for
this reason
what happened in the past
was when you had no awareness of how
things worked
and the significance of that is
um
yes you were involved with your cancer
but you had no knowledge of any
involvement and i go so why is this
relevant the answer is this
very important words you brought up such
as victim guilt shame
blame
i go where do they come from well those
words
like uh guilt
guilt means i knew there was a right way
to do something but then i chose to not
do it that way now i'm guilty but if i
didn't know there was a right way to do
it then how the heck can i be guilty
nobody told me and all of a sudden i go
back and i say without knowledge your
behavior in the past was based on not
being aware
and therefore the concept of blame and
guilt chain victim all that does not
apply
it only applies to those people who knew
there was a right way
and then chose to do it a different way
that was a personal decision i would be
guilty if i knew i was doing something
that was wrong and continue to do it so
let's drop those words for the important
reason
what happened in the past without any
awareness how can you be responsible for
something you have no idea about right
okay
but
today now once we start talking about
this all of a sudden it says well wait a
minute
you are creating this
and you're creating this with your
consciousness and this is let me just
back up because that's the biology the
epigenetics mind
controls not just what genes are being
activated but mine can alter the
blueprint
i can make 3 000 different proteins from
the same blueprint just based on how i
see the world so all of a sudden it says
wow we are very powerful we're the
architects and we can create health
we can also create disease because we're
the creator of it okay so now comes the
the big part and that is this
to me the most valid science on this
planet is quantum physics quantum
physics i say that because
uh back in 1927 when it was theoretical
they came up with a whole bunch of
things you know albert einstein max
planck heisenberg that came up with a
theory of how everything worked well
it's nearly 100 years and guess what
almost all of their theories are totally
accurate so
we have a deep deep understanding of
quantum physics
consciousness
is creating our life experience
principle number one it was back in 1927
max planck founder one of the founders
said the mind is the matrix of all
matter
[Music]